Dann legen wir los. Ah ne, Moment, ich muss ja den Code Opener machen. Sekunde, vielleicht jetzt. Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Männerfußball und wir schauen damit mit Nils Kern auf La Liga, mit Christian Bernhard auf die Serie A, mit Uli Hebel auf die Premier League, mit Daniel Zander auf die Eredivisie und mit Jakob Haffke auf die Liga. Da soll noch einer sagen, hier werden nicht alle Ligen abgedeckt. Und nein, kein Portugal. Meldet euch einfach nicht. Jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Toll.
Also, der hat jetzt im Winter unterschrieben und das war jetzt nicht einfach nur so, ja, komm, hier, kurzer Vertrag, sondern 5,5. Also, da scheint wirklich auch großes Vertrauen einfach in ihn da zu sein. Ja, schöne Geschichte.
Weißt du, dass zufällig, wenn er sich jetzt wieder in die Nationalmannschaft reinspielen würde, dürfte er dann auf italienischem Boden auflaufen?
Gute Frage, Max. Habe ich jetzt nicht parat, aber könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das womöglich bei Heimspielen nicht gehen würde. Weil, wie gesagt, da redet ja die italienische, sozusagen, da geht es ja auch um italienische medizinische Standards. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die auch für Nationalmannschaftsspiele gelten. Also, ja, das ist ein spannendes Thema. Also, wenn es wirklich so kommen sollte, ob er dann, unter Anführungszeichen, ein auswärts Nationalspieler werden würde.
Die andere Form des Legionärs.
Ja, genau. Also, ich würde es nicht ausschließen, dass es wirklich auf italienischen Boden einfach nicht geht, sozusagen.
Aber das ist jetzt, glaube ich, viel zu... Genau.
Es geht hier nicht mehr weiter. Genau, absolut. Es ist schön. Er hat sich zurückgebissen, hat auch ja immer direkt danach schon gesprochen, nach dem Vorfall, er möchte alles dafür tun, wieder auf den Platz zurückzukommen. Und ja, war jetzt ein großes Echo in Italien. Und ja, können wir ihm, glaube ich, alle die Daumen drücken.
Aber wirklich, das tun wir. Christian, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank. Du verabschiedest dich an dieser Stelle. Bis bald mal wieder in der Ligatur. Mach's gut.
Ja, danke. Sorry, dass ich jetzt so abrupt los muss. Ich wünsche euch noch ganz viel Spaß. Danke schön.
Ciao.
So, und Nils, wenn du magst, dann darfst du mal weitermachen. Du hast uns ein bisschen Chaos mitgebracht. Diesmal aber nicht kontrolliertes Chaos, wie wir es gerade bei den Nijmegen hatten.
Ja, so ungefähr. Nö, es ist immer wieder typisch La Liga, was da so los ist. Es geht jetzt gar nicht unbedingt um die sportliche Situation. Bei RAIO war Elcano. Die sind als Tabellen 17 natürlich in akuter Abstiegsgefahr. Aber bei RAIO ist jetzt die letzten Heimspiele. Was passiert oder nicht passiert, wo man drüber reden muss, was sinnbildlich für einen Club ist, der natürlich irgendwo als Kultig gilt. Und ja, ich bin auch einmal im Jahr gerne dort und denke mir, hier riecht es wieder was schön nach Urin. Also das Stadion ist super runtergewirtschaftet und sogar so super runtergewirtschaftet, dass das auch…
Dieses Kultig, okay.
Das ist das Kultig. Oh, wow, hier ist alles voller Dreck und Tauben, Kot und Ratten, na, das ist irgendwie… Manche sagen halt, das ist kultig und historisch. Jetzt war es eben so weit, dass sie, sie hätten am 7. Februar ein Heimspiel gegen Real Oviedo haben müssen. Das wäre um 14 Uhr gewesen und um 10.14 Uhr kam vom La Liga-Verband die Absage. Weil, nicht weil irgendwie, das gab es auch schon mal, es wurden mal Kabel durchgeschnitten, da ist dann ein Spiel von Riamat Ripp dort ausgefallen, also durch irgendwie Sachbeschädigung. Nö, weil der Platz nicht in guten Bedingungen war, dass dort das Gesundheitsrisiko für die Spieler zu hoch, zu gefährlich war. Wirklich absoluter Flickenteppich seit Monaten eigentlich schon. Und wie gesagt, es geht nicht nur darum, dass rund um das Stadion Flutlichtanlage aus, ich weiß nicht, den 60ern und alles irgendwie, man traut sich nicht auf die Sitzschalen hinzusetzen und die Kabinen, es war mal Lech Posen zu Conference League Spiel dort im Einsatz. Die hatten dann so eine kleine Room Tour durch die Kabine gemacht und man denkt sich, oh mein Gott, wie konnten die überhaupt die Lizenz für Conference League bekommen? Haben sich dort ja auch sportlich gut geschlagen, direkt qualifiziert für die K.o. Runde. Also sportlich ist das eine bei Radio, aber das drum herum um den Club ist ja teils katastrophal. An dem Vortag von dieser Spielabsage gegen Real Oviedo hatte sogar noch die Spanische Spieler-Gewerkschaft AFE eine Mitteilung rausgebracht von der ersten Mannschaft, also von den Spielern direkt, die da die ganzen Missstände mal darauf hingewiesen haben, dass sie teilweise gar nicht auf dem Trainingsgelände trainieren können, dass auch die Jugend- und Frauenabteilung komplett vernachlässigt werden. Es gab auch schon unter der Saison Berichte von irgendwie Schiedsrichtern, die irgendwie benutzte Handtücher dann angeboten bekommen nach so einem Spiel und wirklich katastrophale Zustände. Und da sind wir jetzt bei dem großen Namen, wo der natürlich da die primäre Verantwortung trägt. Das ist der Präsident Martin Presa oder genauer sogar der Eigentümer des Klubs, der schon seit Jahren da im Fokus der Fans ist. Da hört man schon öfter mal Presa, WD, ja, also Presa, hau ab. Der, wie gesagt, den Klub da enorm runterwirtschaftet. Und jetzt gab es diese eine Absage gegen Real Oviedo. Nachholt Spieltermin noch nicht in Sicht und das Spiel danach gegen Atletico. Da mussten sie dann ausweichen. Sie haben zwar versucht, neuen Rasen anzuflanzen, aber auch der sieht sehr flickenmäßig aus. Und das hat nicht gereicht, so ist dann am vergangenen Wochenende ein Erstligaspiel in den Zweitliga-Stadion in Leganés gestiegen. Das hat Raio dann auch mit 3-0 verdient gegen Atletico gewonnen. Auch irre. Aber ja, viel, viel Chaos und eigentlich katastrophale Lage um den Klub, der eigentlich schon nicht mal Europa-Pokal-Lizenz haben dürfte. Aber Erstligalizenz hatte ich mich schon auch gewundert, dass die überhaupt noch in der Liga spielen dürfen.
Aber kann man mit wenigen Worten sagen, warum Martin Preser den Verein so verkommen lässt?
Ja, das kann man sagen. Er hat natürlich primär wirtschaftliche Ziele und hofft und spekuliert so ein bisschen darauf, dass er mit der Unterstützung von Stadt und Land, Regierung, Steuergelder, da vielleicht einen Neubau starten kann. Also sein großes Ziel ist mehr aus RAIO rauszupressen, als irgendwie nur mit diesen, was sind es, 15.000 Ministadion. Es gab da zwar jetzt auch schon mal einen Entwurf von einem Umbau, aber RAIO ist ja auch sehr, sehr, das Stadion ist ja auch sehr engen Raum, wo hinter dem einen Tor ist ja gar keine Tribüne, weil da die Hochhäuser stehen. Also er versucht irgendwie ein bisschen wie beim FC Valencia. Peter Lieben, der hat es jetzt schlussendlich hinbekommen, durch den Druck mit der WM 2030, den Valencia, die Valencia sonst verpasst hätte, dass dort dann sich Stadt und Land eingemischt haben und gesagt, komm, jetzt gib mal mal ein paar Steuergelder in den Umbau des Nürburgringes, dort hat es geklappt. Und jetzt hier Martin Preser hofft so ein bisschen auf das Gleiche, dass da eben irgendwann mit staatlicher Hilfe dann irgendwie einen Umbau oder vielleicht sogar einen Neubau bekommt, weil auch da jetzt das Thema mit Umverlegung nach Leganes. Das war natürlich den Fanzen Dorn im Auge und auch die vielen Dauerkarteninhaber, ich glaube, das sind so 11.000, 12.000 rum, die haben das Spiel boykottiert, weil sie eben nicht gute Bilder haben wollten, im Sinne von, Leganes kriegen sie ja auch voll und warum spielen sie nicht öfter da so in der Martin Preser-Denke, sondern da sind, wie gesagt, große Proteste. Und vorhin hatte Jakob schon den Begriff dimision gebracht, das hört man auch in Spanien oft, also dimision ist so die Rücktrittsforderung, bei bei Rallo ist es mittlerweile der Begriff inhabilitation, also dass man ihm die Rechte abnimmt, dass man ihm das Recht abnimmt, den Club weiter zuführen. Enteignung, genau.
Sauber, wir müssen mehr über Enteignung sprechen, Leute. Stark, da war ich richtig auf.
Später habe ich noch so ein Karls Club, da fällt der Begriff auch hier und da mal.
Lass uns zum Fußball anfangen und dann aber ganz, ganz schnell bei großen Konzernen und Milliardären weitermachen.
Grüße an Bonovia. Und was wir sonst noch so haben.
Unter anderem. Aber das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Ich freue mich jetzt schon auf die Kommentare. Okay, also aber schön, dass wir ein neues Kapitel haben in der Endlossage. Mit Investoren, die Premier League einholen, auch bei Rallo. Ein Erfolgsmodell, Sondersgleichen. Einfach toll, das Schicksal eines ganzen Clubs in die Hand eines einzelnen Menschen zu legen. Danke dir, lieber Nils. Jakob, wenn du magst, dann darfst du auch direkt weitermachen. Was hast du denn in der Liga A noch für ein kurzes Thema? Ach ja, stimmt, klar, da haben wir ja auch Chaos. Das war ja eigentlich meine Übung. Deswegen wollte ich ja jetzt zu dir gehen. Was macht denn Olympique Marseille so?
Ja, haben wir auch lange nicht mehr drüber gesprochen. Eigentlich ja ungewöhnlich, dass man zweimal in Folge über den das gleiche Team spricht. Aber jetzt hat Marseille sich das, glaube ich, sehr zu Herzen genommen, dass sie hier in der Liga Tour Dauergast sein wollen. Und wir hatten ja in der letzten Woche oder vor zwei Wochen über die sportlichen Missstände gesprochen. Und das man kann, glaube ich, zu Recht behaupten, dass das jetzt ein wenig eskaliert ist in den letzten Wochen. Denn es gab dann ja zuerst die Niederlage im Le Classique 0 zu 5. Also wirklich peinlich die höchste Niederlage, die Marseille jemals gegen Paris erlitten hat. Und angesichts der besonderen Rivalität zwischen den beiden kam das nicht so richtig gut an. Danach hat Roberto de'Servi auch gesagt, dass er hilflos, also er hat nicht explizit gesagt, er sei hilflos, aber er hat gesagt, er versteht seine Mannschaft nicht. Und das war dann eigentlich klar, okay, das kann nicht mehr lange dauern. Dann hat Marseille mitten in der Nacht von Dienstag auf Mittwoch auch eine Pressebeteilung rausgegeben, dass de'Servi nicht mit länger Trainer sein soll. Es war angeblich eine einvernehmliche Trennung. Allerdings ist das dann ja meistens auch ein bisschen Wortglauberei. Damit war das Ganze aber längst noch nicht ausgestanden. Man hat dann erst mit Jacques Abaddonado aus innerhalb des Vereins eine Interims-Lösung gefunden. Vor dem Spiel am Wochenende gegen Straßburg gab es dann aber auch schon Proteste von den Fans, die de'Servi so ein bisschen als Bauernopfer gesehen haben. Die Proteste richteten sich vor allem gegen Präsident Pablo Longoria und auch den Eigentümer Frank McCord. Der wurde sehr blumig bezeichnet als der Kapitän eines Geisterschiffes, das niemals die andere Seite des Ozeans erreichen würde.
Und es ist Christian Ilzer irgendwie Kapo bei den Ultras von Marseille, ist ja fantastisch.
Ja, habe ich mir auch gedacht. Und genau dann, also gegen diese beiden gab es den Protesten, ein bisschen kurios. 15 Minuten lang haben die Ultras auch das Spiel boykottiert, sind dann erst auf die Ränge geströmt. Just als sie ins Stadion kamen, ging Marseille in Führung. Dann sah es eigentlich auch so aus, als würde zumindest sportlich so ein bisschen ein Befreiungsschlag erfolgen. Dann führte man 2-0, hat sich dann aber erneut in der Nachspielzeit noch den Ausgleich gefangen, so den Sieg verspielt. Ist jetzt das siebte Gegentor in dieser Saison, was Marseille in der Nachspielzeit der zweiten Halbzeit gefangen hat und damit noch Punkte verspielt hat. Aber das eigentliche Theater ging dann danach weiter, denn es war dann nicht Pablo Longoria oder Frank McCourt, die zuerst Konsequenzen gezogen haben, sondern Sportdirektor Mehdi Benassia hat mehrmals versucht, zurückzutreten, muss man wohl sagen. Denn er hat seinen Rücktritt eingereicht, wohl auch mehrmals. Er hat das dann auch öffentlich bestätigt, dass er wirklich zurücktreten möchte. Es sah dann auch erst so aus, als wäre das dann tatsächlich der Fall. Und dann kam jetzt aber im Laufe dieser Woche die Wende, weil Frank McCourt, der Eigentümer, sich explizit darum bemüht haben soll, dass Benassia bleibt als Sportdirektor, zumindest bis zum Ende der Saison. Und dann hat er sich auch weich klopfen lassen. Oder es wird auch spekuliert, dass es reine Taktik war von Benassia, ein sehr gelungenes Machtspiel. Denn er hat viele von seinen Vertrauten auch überall im Verein installiert. Er ist also eigentlich auch schon so der heimliche starke Mann gewesen. Und jetzt ist er auch seit ein paar Tagen dann wohl wirklich der starke Mann. Denn gleichzeitig hat Frank McCourt auch gesagt, dass Pablo Longoria, also der Präsident, eigentlich nur noch repräsentative Aufgaben haben soll. Also da hat dann sozusagen ein Machtwechsel stattgefunden. Benassia ist jetzt zumindest bis zum Sommer der starke Mann. Denn was danach ist, ist auch unklar. Er ist also auch damit beauftragt gewesen, jetzt einen neuen Trainer zu finden. Gleichzeitig soll Pablo Longoria jetzt eigentlich auch zurücktreten wollen, was allerdings auch nicht im Sinne von Marseille sein kann. Denn mit ihm haben sie einen Sitz im Liga-Verband. Und diesen Sitz im Liga-Verband würden sie verlieren, wenn Pablo Longoria zurücktritt. Denn das ist an eine Person gebunden und nicht an den Verein. Und ein Nachfolger muss mindestens ein Jahr im Amt gewesen sein, um kandidieren zu können. Das heißt, dann würde Marseille diese wichtige Machtposition innerhalb der Liga verlieren. Also wird das jetzt auch nochmal spannend, wie sich das da entwickelt und hinzieht. Und was aber jetzt erfolgt ist, gestern Abend hat Marseille dann bekannt gegeben, dass sie einen neuen Trainer gefunden haben mit Habib Bey. Ja, ist jetzt nicht so eine sonderlich inspirierende Lösung, finde ich zumindest. Der ist ja vor wenigen Tagen, inzwischen sind es zwei Wochen, in bei Startrennen entlassen worden. Hat allerdings als Spieler auch eine Geschichte bei Marseille. Also hat lange da gespielt, war auch Kapitän des Teams. Kennt also sozusagen den Verein zumindest. War jetzt bei Startrennen auch nicht unerfolgreich. Allerdings, ja, ich glaube nicht, dass der so jetzt bei den Fans als absolute Traumlösung ankommen wird zuerst. Er hat natürlich, kann er die Fans sicherlich überzeugen mit sportlichem Erfolg. Aber wo so ein bisschen ich auch schon wieder Potenzial für Unruhe sehe, dass er bei Startrennen auch vor allem nicht wegen seiner sportlichen Erfolglosigkeit, sondern wegen Konflikten mit der Kabine entlassen wurde, weil er sich wohl mit den erfahrenen Spielern oft gezofft hat. Also Brice Samba, der Torwart, wurde von ihm aussortiert. Andere Spieler wie Seco Fofana oder andere Führungsspieler sind auch gegangen dann im Winter, weil sie mit ihm überhaupt nicht zurechtgekommen sind. Und dass er jetzt eine Kabine mit noch viel mehr größeren Charakteren führen soll, klingt jetzt zumindest nicht auf den ersten Blick plausibel. Und generell muss man auch sagen, dass die Trainerwechsel jetzt auch in dieser Saison in Ligue 1 überhaupt nicht funktioniert haben. Es hat tatsächlich kein einziger neuer Trainer bisher, zumindest was den Tabellenplatz angeht, eine Verbesserung herbeiführen können, was, glaube ich, eine durchaus bemerkenswerte Statistik ist. Wir hatten das ja vorhin bei Monaco schon gesagt. Bei Nantes gab es einen Trainerwechsel kurz vor Weihnachten. Luiz Castro weg, Ahmed Kantari da. Die sind weiterhin 17. Da sind sogar eher noch schlechter geworden. Bei Nizza gab es ja eine Trainerentlassung von Frank Aas, der jetzt übrigens Nachfolger von Abib Bey bei Start rennen wird. Also da auch eine schöne Rotation innerhalb der Liga. Da ist mit Claude Puel ein alter Bekannter wieder zurück, der allerdings auch eher vielleicht zumindest mal wieder gewonnen. Aber Nizza ist trotzdem weiter abgerutscht in der Tabelle. Bei Metz gab es noch einen Trainerwechsel. Die sind aber weiterhin relativ chancenlos 18er. Also bisher bringen die Trainerwechsel auch nichts. Mal gucken, ob das jetzt bei Marseille vielleicht anders sein wird. Kurzfristiges Ziel ist natürlich jetzt erstmal noch unter die ersten drei zu kommen und damit dann die direkte Champions League Qualifikation zu holen und sicherlich nicht zu vernachlässigen, den Pokal zu gewinnen. Denn da ist Marseille ja zumindest noch im Rennen.
Und PSG schon draußen. Also Marseille, auf gar keinen Fall werden wir dieses Saison beenden können, in der Ligatour, ohne noch mal über Olympique zu sprechen. Deswegen lassen wir es dabei bewenden. Und ehrlich gesagt, mir reicht es jetzt mit den Negativgeschichten. Ich will endlich mal über ein Team sprechen, das zwar im Abstiegskampf hängt, das aber gerade Anzeichen von Leben zeigt, das eben zeigt, vielleicht geht es da unten raus. Und Uli, damit sind wir bei West Ham gelandet. Und das hätte man vor vier, fünf Spieltagen nicht unbedingt gedacht.
Ja, stimmt. Scheint so zu sein, als würde Nuno Spirito Santo immer seine halbe Saison brauchen, um irgendwo anzukommen. Das ist auch diesmal wieder der Fall gewesen. Was im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Tatsache so ist, weil er jemand zu sein scheint, der vor allen Dingen die Menschen hinter den Spielern mitzunehmen scheint. Und das kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass es ein gutes halbes Jahr dauert, dass er dann einfach mal einen gewissen Zugang bekommt zu denen. Neben ein paar Minianpassungen, die er vorgenommen hat, die er aber auch fairerweise schon vor einem halben Jahr probiert hat, die da nicht funktioniert haben, die aber jetzt langsam, aber sicher minimal fruchten. Das ist die eine Wahrheit und die andere ist, dass der Rest auch nicht richtig vom Fleck wegkommt. Führt dazu im Übrigen, das ist jetzt so mein Take. Ich glaube, der Absteiger, mal abgesehen davon, dass es punktetechnisch auch im Moment so zu sein scheint, wenn man alles hochrechnet, dann könnte es sein, dass der diesjährige letzte Absteiger mit fast 40 Punkten runtergeht. Aber so oder so, egal, wenn es jetzt noch erwischt von da unten. Tottenham ist ja inzwischen auch mit drin in diesem Abstiegskampf, wenn gleich sie schon noch ein bisschen Vorsprung haben. Aber sei es Tottenham, sei es Nottingham, sei es dann auch West Ham. Der dritte Absteiger ist, glaube ich, der stärkste, der jemals aus der Premier League abgestiegen ist.
Krass. Und das bringt uns ja zum übergeordneten Thema, dass wir eben noch mal kurz auf den Abstiegskampf generell gucken. Also West Ham scheint ja dann zumindest Anlass zur Hoffnung zu haben. Wem würdest du denn sagen, kannst du am ehesten gerade erwischen? Tottenham hat auch reagiert. Ist es Nottingham?
Tottenham hat reagiert. Nottingham hat schon zum vierten Mal insgesamt reagiert in der Saison, obwohl ich gar nicht groß war. Da muss es auch irgendwas Atmosphärisches geben. Featuring, Marinakis, der Besitzer da, der ist halt einfach manchmal fiebrig und reagiert ganz häufig darauf, wenn das Publikum ungehalten wird. Und die haben schon ein wenig Geduld verloren, eben auch weil West Ham angeschoben hat. Das war nämlich eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht unter Sean Deitch. Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt unter Vitor Pereira großartig viel besser wird, der ja auch erst in dieser Saison die Wolves verlassen hat, die ja weiterhin unten drin stehen. Also das ist auch so eine ganz eigene Sache, dass die da untereinander sich die Trainer zuschieben im Moment. Das ist ganz klassische Feuerwehrmann-Lösungen. Vitor Pereira ist never ever, wenn wir im Februar 27 noch mal Ligatour machen, da Trainern, die malz. Ich halte noch nicht mal für komplett ausgeschlossen, dass die noch mal was tun, die letzten zwei Spieltage. Weil der einfach, der will, das ist ja klar, die haben sich einen teuren Kader geleistet. Die müssen auch drin bleiben bei Nottingham. Ansonsten fällt der Verein vielleicht sogar komplett und final auseinander. Deswegen müssen die mit aller Macht da irgendwie drin bleiben. Die fand ich aber gar nicht so schlecht eigentlich. Und die haben natürlich einfach, wenn du den Kader schaust, einfach eine wahnsinnige Qualität da drin, die West Ham auch zum Teil hat, aber halt nur zum Teil. Also der Kader ist schon etwas zerrupfter als bei Nottingham. Und Tottenham ist vermutlich halt minimal zu gut dafür, als dass die nochmal so richtig mit reingeraten würden. Das Witzige ist ja das, dass also die Wolves, die sind ja schon eigentlich seit immer, die haben ja gar nicht gewonnen eine ganze Zeit lang. Die sind eigentlich schon seit immer weg. Die haben jetzt zum Beispiel gestern Abend Arsenal einen Punkt, oder zwei Punkte sogar geklaut, im wahrsten Sinne. Das heißt, da entscheiden sie fleißig mit, sind aber trotzdem wahrscheinlich ab vom Schuss. Und bei Burnley ist es so, auch der Punkt, der Abstand, ist natürlich einfach wahnsinnig gering. Und sie spielen bestenfalls unentschieden, aber gewinnen nicht, weil da, glaube ich, die individuelle Qualität einfach nicht da ist. Aber da gibt es immer mal auch so Wochen, wo ich denke, Mensch, vielleicht sind sie doch wieder da. Und die haben sich auch gar nicht so schlecht verstärkt, noch mal im Winter, aber vermutlich wird es trotzdem nicht reichen. Ja, also ist es nicht ganz leicht zu sagen, im Moment wirkt Nottingham sehr viel zerfahrener als West Ham. Das ist so die aktuelle Bestandsaufnahme. Das mag sich natürlich auch schnell wieder ändern. Weil, muss man ja auch sagen, minus dieser einen Saison, die es jetzt letztes Jahr gab bei Nottingham, wo es einfach in die andere Richtung dynamisch lief, nämlich, dass alles einfach plötzlich funktioniert hat, haben sie das ja schon zweimal in Folge davor gemacht. Und da war jeweils das Publikum der absolute Gamechanger, weil die Stimmung trotzdem derart positiv war, weil sie im Grunde mit nichts anderem gerechnet haben. Es kann schon sein, dass sich dieser Effekt auch wieder einstellt, wie der Pereira es nicht schlecht in Sachen Umfeldversicht gewinnen.
Ja, und ich meine, wenn ein Punkte diesmal nicht vor Abstieg schützen, wer weiß, ob wir da vielleicht dann doch nochmal über Leeds, doch nochmal über Brighton sprechen, hatten wir ja auch zuletzt mit hier in der Ligatour.
Genau, also Leeds nehme ich fast schon gar nicht mehr mit rein, weil das Komplizierteste, was die zu erledigen hatten, war eigentlich so von Anfang Dezember bis Ende Januar. Ich hätte nie damit gerechnet, dass Daniel Fakir noch im Amt ist. Niemals. Also mir war klar, wir haben auch immer so im Podcast gesagt, der wird, wenn es hochkommt, darf er noch Weihnachten machen, weil die wollten den da eh nie haben. Und mit dem Programm kann der eigentlich nur verlieren. Und der ist für jeden einzelnen Gegner ein schwieriges Spiel im Moment, sodass ich Leads fast schon, also die sind bei mir so fast schon weg, weil die sind so funktionell. Das ist ja ganz oft so, dass wenn Teams wie Nottingham etwas ungefragt da unten reinkommen, dann haben sie Schwierigkeiten zu adaptieren. Und die machen ja auch noch diesen Spagat. Das ist ja das Seltsame. Weil auf der einen Seite kämpfen sie ums blanke Überleben, auf der anderen Seite redet Marinakis schon auch intern wohl darüber, dass sie den Europapokal gewinnen wollen, in dem sie ja noch vertreten sind. Das heißt, da sind sie auch unter Jean Deitsch vor allen Dingen richtig gut gewesen. Es sah lange Zeit noch danach aus, als würden sie sich direkt qualifizieren können und eben nicht in die Zwischenrunde müssen. Was natürlich bitter ist für einen englischen Verein, wenn er jetzt noch sozusagen dann Donnerstag, Donnerstag im Einsatz ist. Und das ist auf der anderen Seite bei Lied. Die haben sich von Anfang an nichts vorgemacht, dass es ums nackte Überleben gehen wird. Und das merkt man denen an. Und da hat Daniel Fahke, gerade auch, das hätte ich ihm niemals zugetraut nach Gladbacher Zeiten, eine richtig wehrhafte Defensive, also Umschalten von der Offensive in die Defensive, eingebaut. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das gibt bei ihm, aber es ist sogar soweit gehe ich, wenn das klappt. Einer der Favoriten Coach of the Year.
Ha, krass.
Okay, da müssen wir demnächst nochmal länger drüber sprechen. Aber Uli, auch du musst jetzt los. Ich habe, wenn ich es richtig ergoogelt habe, wir haben uns in einer kurzen Pause gerade gefragt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, welches Klassikstück das ist, wo nacheinander alle Instrumente aufhören zu spielen. Und das auch damals so als mögliche Rebellion gegen den damaligen Fürsten gesehen wurde. Es müsste die Overtüre zum Freischütz gewesen sein. Die spielen wir jetzt nach und verabschieden auch Uli. Schöner wurdest du noch nie verabschiedet, Uli. Gibst du. Danke dir für deine Zeit.
Mein Lieber, vielen Dank.
Auch ein. Bis bald. So, und wir machen weiter. Daniel, du hast gefühlt drei Stunden schon nichts mehr sagen dürfen. Es tut mir leid. Ich musste gerade richtig überlegen, wer ist jetzt überhaupt noch dran? Ja, Daniel, du auf jeden Fall. Was haben wir denn noch so in der Ehredivise oder in den Niederlanden generell zu besprechen?
Genau. Und im Gegensatz zu den Instrumenten, die sich verabschieden könnten, in den Niederlanden bald Dinge hinzukommen, wie Beleidigungen und dann Stern. Also es ist sehr interessant, was gerade passiert. Also Hintergrund ist in den Niederlanden, gibt es keine offene Pyramidensysteme in der Liga. Das heißt, wir haben die erste Liga, wir haben die zweite, das ist die sogenannte Kölken Kampioen Divisi, ein furchtbarer Sponsor, ist aber auch schon Kult geworden. Es stinkt zwar nicht nach Rhin, wie in Spanien, aber es ist auch eine Art von Kult, die KKD, die Kölken Kampioen Divisi. Und aus der kann man fast nicht absteigen. Es gibt eine Ausnahme für die U23-Teams, das sind die Young-Teams, Young Ajax, Young PSV. Die können unter Umständen absteigen in Ausnahmefällen. Aber eigentlich ist das nur ein System. Nach der 2. Liga kommt dann die 3. Liga, die heißt da 2. Divisi. Und da ist das Problem, was viele Amateur-Clubs haben, dass sie mittlerweile eigentlich strukturell und auch sportlich schon das Niveau sehr gesteigert haben in den letzten Jahren. Und die sind eigentlich durchaus vergleichbar mit einigen Zweitligisten, können aber trotzdem wissenschaftlich aufsteigen. Deshalb ein typisches geschlossenes System, was in den letzten Jahren immer mehr für Missstände gesorgt hat. Und vor einer Woche ungefähr kamen dann einige Amateur-Clubs zum Verband, KNVB, und haben ihr Leid geklagt und sich dafür aufgesprochen, dass man dieses System wieder öffnet. Und die Chancen dafür stehen auch ganz gut. Also man hat das damals eingeführt, weil eben die Differenz und die Kluft zwischen Amateur-Teams und Profi-Teams sehr, recht groß war. Also wir reden auch wirklich von so Ackerplätzen. Und da ist dann, war wirklich nicht viel da. Und das hat sich eben verändert. Und viele fühlen sich von den Amateur-Clubs bereit, eben diesen Schritt zu gehen, bei einem Aufstieg, also bei dem möglichen Aufstieg, dann eben auch wirklich aufzusteigen. Und nicht wie jetzt ein Blut draussen bekommen. Und das nette Worte. Und das könnte in den nächsten ein, zwei Jahren sogar schon passieren, heißt es da. Und ich halte es auch für sehr wahrscheinlich und realistisch, als das klappt. Und dann können tolle Vereine wie The Treffers und die Kosakken Boys können dann in den Profifußball aufsteigen. Und das würde ich zum anderen nehmen, mal diese schöne 2. Liga, diese KKLD, noch mal ein bisschen näher zu erklären. Weil da gibt es ein, zwei Sachen, die, glaube ich, sehr bemerkenswert sind. Und es ist vor allem die Regelung des Aufstiegs zwischen ihrer Division und der 2. Liga. Das ist herausragend. Also es fängt relativ simpel an. Meister und Bielsten müssen aufsteigen. Das ist recht easy in ihrer Division. Und dann gibt es die Playoffs. Und diese Playoffs bestreiten 6 weitere Teams aus der 2. Liga. Es gibt insgesamt 20 Vereine. Und trotzdem ist es eine Ansage mit 6 weiteren neben den ersten beiden, dass die mitspielen dürfen um diesen Aufstieg. Und die werden aber nicht nur über das Liga qualifiziert, sondern es gibt 38 Spieltage und diese werden in 4 Perioden aufgeteilt. Spieltag 1 bis 10, Spieltag 11 bis 19 und so weiter. Also die ungefähr so alle neun oder vier Spieltage haben. Und es gibt dann vier Periodenmeister. Das bedeutet, wenn ich jetzt, wenn die mir zum Beispiel mal Dortrecht, die sind gerade auf Platz 6 der Tabelle, wenn die jetzt an Spieltag 10 bis 11 bis 19 alles gewinnen, die Spiele, dann haben die diese Periode gewonnen und bekommen damit neben so einem schönen Pokal, so einem Schild auch das Zicke für die Playoffs. Daraus entsteht natürlich die Möglichkeit, dass Dortrecht sonst nichts gewinnt. Die können komplett miserabel in die Saison gestartet sein. Die können dann irgendwie acht Spieltage in Folge gewinnen, weil vielleicht die Form gut ist, weil vielleicht die Gegner nominell schwächer sind, weil sie nicht gegen die ersten müssen und so. Können dann gewinnen, können dann nach wie der alles verlieren und könnten dann rein theoretisch als Tabellen 15. um den Aufstieg spielen. Das ist möglich. Und das ist natürlich ein System. Es ist wahnsinnig, wenn man sich überlegt, man wird dann eventuell dafür belohnt, dass man von 38 Spieltagen bei 9 gewonnen hat oder so. Aber so ist es. Und dann hat man diese vier Periodenmeister. Dann kommen noch zwei Vereine hinzu, die dann an der Endtabelle, nach denen die besten sind, neben den Periodenmeistern und den beiden Deckaufsteigern. Und die spielen dann mit dem Rückspiel in einem KO-Turnier aus, wer dann letztendlich gegen den 16. Eredivisie in der eigenen Kollegation spielen darf. Das heißt, die fangen auch, glaube ich, schon irgendwie Ende März, Anfang April mit diesen Sachen an. Weil du brauchst ja auch Zeit dafür, wenn du so von dir veranstaltest. Und es gibt auch ein bisschen Kritik aus der Eredivisie bzw. von der zweiten Liga an der Eredivisie. Früher war es so, vor ein paar Jahren, dass der Tabellensechzehnte schon früher in dieses Turnier eingestiegen ist. Ich glaube, schon im Halbfinale musste er dann ran und dann eben auch noch mal im Finale. Und seit der aktuellen Saison ist es so, dass der Tabellensechzehnte der ersten Liga auch erst im Finale dann dazugeschaltet wird. Das hat quasi wie in Deutschland wirklich nur ein Hin- und Hinsichtsspiel an der Relegation. Und das heißt, es macht es für die Tabellensechze für den ersten Ligisten dann noch mal einfacher, die Klasse über die Relegation zu halten, als das noch vor ein paar Jahren war. Das hat man vor allem gemacht, weil der Kalender schon so aufgebläht war, als man da gesagt hat, ihr kriegt ein Hin- und Hinsichtsspiel weniger. Und ja, so ist die Situation in der 2. Liga mit diesem Playoff. Das hat natürlich Vor- und Nachteile. Aber ich glaube, dass es für mich persönlich die Nachteile überwiegt, wenn man überlegt, da werden Vereine belohnt für 8 gute Spiele in Folge. Und das war es. Zumal man ja auch sagen muss, dadurch, dass es ja noch ein größeres System ist, hast du auch ganz oft das Problem, dass dann gesagt wird, okay, jetzt haben wir 8, 9 Spiele in Folge gewonnen. Wozu jetzt noch großartig anstrengen? Wir sind nicht irgendwie im Bereich, dass wir Meister, Höchstsemester werden können. Absteigen geht ja nicht. Also schwimmen wir mal irgendwie ein halbes Jahr zu Spielern, gucken zu, dass sich da keiner verletzt, oder probieren wir was aus, oder mal gucken. Und können dann bei den Rehausspielen, die aber aufsteigen, theoretisch.
Also ich habe drei Dinge dazu zu sagen. Erstmal, danke, dass du das erklärt hast, weil neulich ist bei Blue Sky in so einem internationalen What's Hot Feed genau das an mir vorbeigeflogen. Und ich habe gar nichts verstanden. Und dachte mir, was ist das überhaupt? Was soll das? Ich verstehe es nicht. Periodenmeister, war auch auf niederländisch. Also ich war auch quasi, es gab eine Sprachbarriere. Okay, jetzt weiß ich, worum es ging. Und das ist deswegen an mir vorbeigeflogen, weil die jetzt nämlich ihren letzten Spieltag haben. Und dann geht es nämlich ja los. Also jetzt 20. Februar. Und dann, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, startet dann eben dieses Playoff-System Platz zwei. Oder das zweite, was ich sagen will. Es ist ganz eindeutig, dass sich die Niederlande das belgische System angeguckt hat und gesehen hat, wie kompliziert das ist und sich gedacht hat, hold my beer, my fruchtversetztes Bier. Und das haben sie gemacht. Und das dritte ist, es gilt die alte Faustregel. Wenn ein Modus so kompliziert ist, dass er ein komplettes Ligatour-Segment braucht, um erklärt zu werden, dann ist es ein schlechter Modus. Dann überwiegen die Nachteile.
Vielleicht noch ein Ding. Ich habe auch nicht zufällig dort recht genommen als Beispiel, weil es ist gerade die dritte Periode, also noch so zehn Spieltage insgesamt. Spielen sie noch, bevor dann die Sablieraufsachen losgehen. Dort recht ist zum Beispiel gerade auf Platz 6. Platz 6 sind irgendwie 13 Punkte hinter Platz 2. Also Direktaufstieg wird dann doch ein bisschen schwierig werden. Die sind aber auf einem guten Weg, die aktuell dritte Periode, die noch, glaube ich, ein, zwei Spieltage geht, zu gewinnen.
Ah, dann geht die nur noch ein Spieltag. Ich bin hier auf die offiziellen Liga-Seite und alles ist auf niederländisch. Also Entschuldigung, ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Es ist aber auch schwierig erklärt. Ich habe mir das auch nochmal so vorbeigeneu angeschaut. Es ist kompliziert. Und dort recht ist also jetzt in der dritten Periode dabei, die zu gewinnen. Da habe ich innerhalb dieser Periodentabelle auch schon mehr Punkte Vorsprung. Sind aber in der Gesamt-Tabelle nur auf Platz 6 haben 3 Punkte oder 4 Punkte vor Fanlo auf 11. Das heißt, die Chancen stehen gut, dass das FC Dortrecht genauso ein Fall wird. Dass sie jetzt eine gute Phase haben, weil die Gegner vielleicht ein bisschen flächer sind nominell oder die Form dann gut ist. Die am Ende aber vermutlich durchaus auf 11, 12 landen könnten. Also im kompletten Niemandsland. Aber Ticket bekommen, das ist ein Kampf der Playoffs.
Das ist wahrscheinlich gut.
Okay, haben wir wieder was dazugelernt. Dann schauen wir noch ein letztes Mal nach Spanien. Irgendwie liegt das an den kurzen Pausen, die wir hatten zwischen den Verabschiedungen. Aber irgendwie wirkt das heute wie eine mehrstündige Aufnahme. Nils, ich hoffe, du bist noch bei Geistiger Frische.
Ich bin doch da. Der Hunger kommt langsam, aber alles okay. Das Thema muss ich auf jeden Fall auch noch loswerden. Eben hatte ich schon Radio-Chaos-Lupen. Jetzt kommt natürlich auch wieder ein Chaos-Club, wo auch immer der Eigentümer in Kritik steht. Redet man gleich auch noch drüber. Aber jetzt am Wochenende war der FC Sevilla gegen Alavis im Einsatz. Also es wird auch mal ein bisschen sportlich haben. 1-1 gespielt, sind weiter in der Abstiegszone. Platz 3 mit 26 Punkten, also 2 Punkte vor Mallorca auf dem ersten Abstiegsrand. Und da ist es dann in der Schlussphase zu einem Platzverweis für den Trainer gekommen. Das ist Matthias Almeida, der ist seit Saisonbeginn da. Durch Abstiegskampf überschaubar erfolgreich bisher. Und ja, jetzt kann man überlegen, dass mal der ein oder andere Trainer vielleicht auch in der Bundesliga schon mal rot gesehen hat, weil er sich vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr aufgeregt hat. Okay, dann ist er vielleicht mal ein, zwei Spiele raus. Aber jetzt müsst ihr euch alle gerne auch zu den Zuhörerinnen mal überlegen, was muss denn ein Trainer machen, um für sieben Spiele gesperrt zu werden? Die Antwort ist, ich kann es euch selber auch nicht ganz erklären, weil es geht nicht ganz heraus. Der Verband hat zwar hier und da gesagt, zwei Spiele da, ein Spiel dafür, aber es ist wirklich eine wilde Situation gewesen da, 85. Minute gegen Alaviz, wo eben so ein kleines Alavels-Foul im Mittelfeld passiert ist. Und Almeyda hat so ein bisschen so, oh man, was ist das jetzt wieder? So geht kurz in die Knie, geht zurück zur Bank. Und dann der Schiedsrichter sieht das so ein bisschen, zirkt aus der Distanz, rote Karte, also komplett unklar, wer hat jetzt rot gesehen, irgendwer vom Staff? Almeyda weiß auch nicht, ich bleibe hier sitzen, weil er hat ja nicht mit mir geredet oder so. Dann geht das Spiel so eine Minute weiter, bis der Schiedsrichter auffällt, der, dem ich gerade aus 10, 20 Metern rot gezeigt habe, der sitzt ja immer noch da. Und dann ging da die Diskussion ein bisschen los, dann ist auch ein Almeyda ein bisschen emotionaler geworden, im Sinne von, dann kam der Schiedsrichter mal entgegen, hat gesagt, hey, du hast übrigens gerade rot gesehen, Almeyda geht hin, eh, wo warst du denn, erklär's mir doch mal. Dann ist es auch ein bisschen kurze Distanz, sieht dann ein bisschen emotionaler aus, ohne dass da jetzt Beleidigungen gefallen sind oder so. Also das ist jetzt von Lippenlesern noch nicht herausgefunden worden, da hat jetzt keiner sich das Trikot drüber gezogen. Und so ist dann irgendwie die Situation auch gar nicht groß eskaliert. Wie gesagt, Almeyda war ein bisschen emotional und dann wurde er auch teilweise noch mal zurückgezogen, hat dann auch mal mit dem 4. Offiziellen geredet, bis er dann in die Kabine schlussendlich gelaufen ist. Und so summiert sich so ein bisschen diese Sperre für ihn, das unter anderem für das, er saß noch auf der Bank, ist nicht gleich in die Kabine, gibt's ein Spielsperre für generelle Proteste gegen den Schiedsrichter, gibt's zwei Spielsperre für eine respektlose Haltung gegenüber den Schiedsrichter, gibt's drei Spielsperre und dann bleibt noch ein generelles Verhalten gegen die gute Ordnung, auch noch ein Spielsperre. Und so kommen irgendwie sieben Spielsperre zusammen, wo man, wenn man sich, wie gesagt, das Spiel oder die Szene anschaut, sich wirklich denkt, hä, was ist da passiert? Also Almeyder sich vielleicht auch danach auf der PK noch entschuldigt, dass es dann, wie gesagt, ein bisschen emotionaler wurde, aber er wusste einfach nicht, worum es ging, was überhaupt er gemeint ist. Und da sieht man mal wieder das Thema, so ein bisschen dünnhäutige, vielleicht vermeintlich arrogante Schiedsrichter. In dem Fall ist es, jetzt kommt ein gefährlicher Name wieder, Josu Galic Apestegui– Apestegui– Apestegui, baskischer Name, der ist 35 Jahre alt, pfeift zum ersten Mal überhaupt in dieser Saison in La Liga. Also er hat jetzt seine ersten 13 La Liga-Spiele auch da. Merkt man vielleicht so ein bisschen, ah, wärst du mal beim Zeigen der roten Karte vielleicht schon eher klarer hingegangen und hättest dich nicht ganz so dünnhäutig präsentiert. Also da ist das schon mal, wie gesagt, eine wilde Szene, wenn man denkt, oh, eine Siebenspiele-Sperre für einen Trainer, der muss ja richtig einen rausgehauen haben. Nö, ist alles irgendwie nicht passiert, wenn es am Ende dann ein, zwei, vielleicht sogar drei Spiele-Sperre gewesen wären. Okay, aber sieben, der Klub will natürlich dagegen vorgehen, steht hinter dem Trainer, logisch. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall mal wieder erwähnenswert.
Und sportlich gesehen, glaubst du, das könnte Sevilla wirklich erwischen? Weil wir alle kennen natürlich Sevilla durch die tausende Europa League-Siege eher so als erfolgreiches Team.
Ja, das ist jetzt die letzten Jahre ein ziemlicher Downfall gewesen. Auch sportliche wie wirtschaftliche Situationen sehr überschaubar. Ich glaube, ich hatte auch mal im Rasenfunk erzählt, dass die beim La Liga Salary Cap der Gehaltsübergrenze mal nur 250.000 Euro zur Verfügung hatten. Das ist mittlerweile natürlich ein bisschen gewachsen, weil so ein paar Großverdiener, wie auch mal ein Rakitic und so weiter, dann noch los geworden sind, aber trotzdem immer noch. Ich glaube, es gibt aktuell Nettoverschuldung, liegt bei 88 Millionen, dann haben sie noch Kredite aufgenommen von 170 Millionen Euro. Das ist jetzt alles mehr und mehr bekannt geworden, weil jetzt ist gerade im Umlauf, dass es einen bekannten Namen gibt, der den Club wohl kaufen will. Und da ist er, der Mann wie ein Rambock. Da ist er, der Ramos. Der will jetzt wahrscheinlich seinen Ex-Club kaufen. Also Sergio Ramos hat da jetzt wohl verschiedene Investoren zusammengetrommelt mit so einer Investorengruppe 511 Capital, um den FC Sevilla zumindest ein Angebot zu unterbreiten. Da wird es jetzt auch juristisch und finanziell schwierig. Es gibt einen LUI, ein Letter of Interest, also eine Absichtserklärung zu kaufen. Jetzt müssen natürlich die Bücher studiert werden. Da sind die Wirtschaftsprüfer vom KPMG wohl dabei, genau zu schauen, wie die Verbindlichkeiten aussehen, welche Gehälter noch ausstehen, welche noch gezahlt werden und alles so mit dem drohenden Abstieg. Aber das ist durchaus eine Option, dass wirklich Sergio Ramos da den Club zumindest übernimmt. Und auch der bisherige Präsident, Jose Maria del Nido Carrasco, den hatte ich auch schon mal erwähnt. Da gibt es auch schon ein paar Juve der Ja-Rufe. Oder man sieht viele Profilbilder im Sinne von Junior. Er ist der Sohn von Ex-Präsidenten, dass der, dem der Rücktritt nahegelegt wird von vielen Fans. Viele Protestaktionen da auch. Dass der offen dafür wäre oder zu viel, hätte er damit dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht zu entscheiden. Aber ja, sportliche Situation ist große Krise, weil der Club sich gerade so irgendwie jetzt seit Jahren über Wasser halten kann. Aber im Endeffekt sind irgendwie hast du 10, 11 Clubs in der Liga, die irgendwie in der Abstiegszone feststecken, wo jeder mal jeden den Punkt abnimmt. Keiner kann sich so richtig festsetzen, außer vielleicht kreativistische, die sich da jetzt raus befreit haben. Dank Matarazzo. Aber gibt mal wieder nicht so viele schöne Storys rund um Sevilla, auch wenn das jetzt rund um Almeida irgendwie sehr drüber und verdient ist.
Aber wirklich. Und 511 Capital. Ich habe das nochmal ganz schnell jetzt versucht, nebenher nachzugucken, weil mir der Name bekannt vorkam. Die versuchen gerade in Fußball reinzukommen. Noch nicht bei großen Teams, bei Espanol waren sie auch im Gespräch. Ich glaube, da ist es mir über den Weg gelaufen. Und sie haben auch schon bei einem ungerischen und einem brasilianischen Verein angeklopft. Und zum Teil sind sie da auch schon mit Minderheitsbeteiligung mit dabei. Das ist so der klassische Fall von, haben Investmentgeld zusammengeholt, so Venture-Capital-mäßig, und wollen jetzt noch irgendwie versuchen, ein Multiclub-Ding aufzuziehen, weil so langsam gibt es ja keine Vereine mehr, die man da reinholen kann. Deswegen, ja.
Da ist ja der FC Sevilla eigentlich schon so halb drin, aber da kennen jetzt viele, wie heißen sie, 777-Partners von Hertha BSC, die es ja dann jetzt doch irgendwie nicht mehr richtig gibt. Die sind eigentlich, oder da gehört noch der FC Sevilla hin, aber das ist dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein totes Investment mittlerweile. Wie gesagt, das könnte gut passieren, dass wirklich Sergio Ramos da mit verschiedenen Investoren-Kumpels sich da einkäuft, aber das wird sich natürlich noch ein paar Wochen ziehen, wenn jetzt Wirtschaftsprüfer da dabei sind. Wenn es dann eh darum geht, ja, der Abstieg ist jetzt realistisch, dann wenn du dann nächste Saison nur noch die Hälfte am Einnahmen hast, wird das noch mal schwieriger oder vielleicht einfacher mit der Übernahme, aber da bin ich dann jetzt auch überfragt.
Ja, und das Ganze mit Triple Seven, das ist jetzt nochmal ein eigenes Thema, weil da wurden ja schon Teile der Beteiligung weiterverkauft, Cap A oder wie auch immer die heißen, die sitzen jetzt auch bei Hertha mit drin und so weiter. Du wirst diese Investoren nicht mehr los. Das ist die Bralle von der Geschichte. Liebe Kinder da draußen und liebe Erwachsenen, legt euch nicht mit Investoren ins Bett, selbst wenn ihr den einen rausgekickt bekommt, legt sich ein anderer hin. Und der hat seine ganz eigenen Interessen. Also das ist einfach gut. Aber unsere Meinung ist da eh klar. Jakob, du bist noch ein letztes Mal dran. Ich bin hier schon völlig verwirrt. Inzwischen, worüber wollen wir denn bei dir noch sprechen? Ich glaube, es geht ja auch um Abstiegskampf.
Ja, aber tatsächlich eine positivere Geschichte aus dem Abstiegskampf, denn es ist ein Team, was tatsächlich nicht den Klassen, der halt schon sicher hat, aber sich zumindest auf einem guten Weg dahin befindet und bei dem man das jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarten konnte vor der Saison. Und das ist AC Le Havre. Die sind auch einer der kleineren Vereine in Frankreich. Wir hatten es jetzt schon häufiger, haben auch im Sommer keinen einzigen Cent für neue– also zumindest keine Ablösen für neue Spieler ausgegeben, sondern ausschließlich ablösefreie Spieler geholt und Spieler geliehen und sind damit aber sehr erfolgreich. Wir stehen jetzt auf Platz 13, 26 Punkte haben neun Punkte Vorsprung schon auf den Relegationsabstiegsplatz. Wir haben jetzt auch zuletzt zwei wichtige Siege eingefahren, zweimal 2 zu 1, besonders jetzt der letzte Sieg auch gegen Toulouse bemerkenswert, weil schon in der ersten Minute der Kapitän und Innenverteidiger Aruna Sangante glatt rot gesehen hat für ein hartes Einsteigen. Also da haben sie wirklich das ganze Spiel in Unterzahl gespielt und trotzdem das Spiel gewonnen. Und ja, maßgeblich dafür verantwortlich ist zum Beispiel ist der Trainer Didier Degas, der hat aus La Afri wirklich ein super unangenehm zu bespielendes Team gemacht. Also die haben die viertbeste Abwehr in der Ligue 1, nur Lens, Lyon und PSG und dann noch Toulouse, die fünftbeste Abwehr. Also die Top 3 und Toulouse haben weniger Gegentore kassiert als La Afri. Und sie haben auch nur einmal mehr als drei Gegentore kassiert, nur dreimal ein Spiel mit mehr als einem Tor. Unterschied verloren, also sie sind immer drin in den Spielen. Erinnert einen vielleicht so ein bisschen an St. Pauli in der letzten Saison. Die Referenz kann ich mir natürlich nicht entgehen lassen, sagen wir es mal so. Sie schießen auch nicht so viele Tore, haben nur 20 Tore geschossen, haben damit den zweitschlechtesten Sturm in der Liga. Das reicht aber. Im Sturm bemerkenswert finde ich Isa Soumaré. Der ist auch so ein Spieler, ja, würde auch super gut zu St. Pauli passen. Er ist nämlich ein Stürmer, der vieles gut kann, aber vor dem Tor wahnsinnig ineffektiv ist. Aber schlechtes ist. Er hat schon zehn Expected Goals gesammelt, aber nur fünf oder sechs Tore daraus gemacht. Sechs gemacht, ja, also performt deutlich unter. Hat jetzt in den letzten beiden Spielen aber dreimal getroffen, auch die beiden Tore beim 2-1 gegen Toulouse gemacht und ist an sich ein richtig cooler Spieler, finde ich. Also kann sich super gut behaupten, haut sich in alles rein, steht in vielen Statistiken wirklich gut da und ja, performt da super, aber ja, ist halt nicht der Treffsicherste. Dann haben sie jetzt im Winter aber mit Soufian Bouffal auch noch einen alten Bekannten geholt, der jetzt auch schon ein bisschen älter ist, aber gleich zwei Vorlagen gegeben hat jetzt, seitdem er da ist, also da auch ganz gut dabei ist und hat und in der Innenverteidigung auch noch zwei interessante Spieler. Da ist nämlich zum einen Gautier Juris, der kleine Bruder von Hugo Juris. Der spielt da jetzt schon länger und jetzt in den letzten drei Spielen hat sich in den Vordergrund gespielt Stefan Sagadou, dessen Stunde schlug dann auch beim 2 zu 1 gegen Straßburg, als er sich hochschraubte im Strafraum wie sein kleiner Bruder, wie sein großer Bruder und dann sein erstes Profitor eingenickt hat. Da auf jeden Fall sich dann auch in den Vordergrund gespielt hat, also das ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr positive Geschichte, zumal auch mit Abdoulaye Toure, einer der zentralen Spieler, jetzt schon länger verletzt fehlt, aber Didier Degas, der da als junger Trainer auch wirklich mit 39 ja auch noch nicht so neu im Geschäft, bei ihm auch schön, dass er aus Le Havre kommt, also da auch in der Jugend gespielt hat als Spieler, also da echt gut etabliert ist und das ist definitiv eine der positiven Geschichten in dieser Saison.
Aber wirklich, also erstmal Respekt, wie tief ihr immer in euren Ligen drin seid, das ist echt fantastisch und ich bin froh, dass das ist der jüngere Bruder von Dan Axel Sagadou ist, weil er ist ja erst 17 Jahre alt, das wäre ein bisschen, wenn er der ältere gewesen wäre, hätte ich Anschlussfragen gehabt. Okay, aber damit haben wir noch einen letzten Blick in die Niederlande zu werfen. Daniel, leider kommen wir nicht in positiver Stimmung aus dieser Sendung raus.
Leider ist es so. Es geht um Oleksandr Tsenchenko. Der ist ja von Arsenal jetzt im Februar am Metlai-Day noch gewechselt zu Ajax. Und wir waren eigentlich alle froh und mutig, dass dadurch das Problem auf den außen verteidiger Position bei Ajax ein bisschen gelöst werden kann. Und dann kam es leider so, dass er sich jetzt beim Startelf-Dibüt, also im zweiten Einsatz überhaupt erst für Ajax, sehr, sehr schlimm verletzt hat. Also, das war nach zwei, drei Minuten schon, Lack auf dem Boden und das kam jetzt raus. Er hatte eine schwere Knieoperation nötig und er fällt jetzt in der Tat bis zur neuen Saison aus. Also, er hatte dann ja insgesamt vielleicht mit der Einwechslung in dem Spiel davor 20 Minuten gespielt für seinen neuen Verein, für Ajax und ist jetzt erstmal raus. Und das ist natürlich an der Stelle vor allem eine gute Besserung, weil er sah schon sehr, sehr unschön aus auf dem Feld gegen Setat und wirft Ajax natürlich persönlich zurück. Also, er hatte ja auch noch spekuliert, auch im Grund für den Wechsel, dass er zur WM-Teilnahme ja noch kann. Also, die Ukraine kämpft ja noch um den WM-Teiltitel und da kann er nicht mit mitwirken. Und auch wenn die Ukraine das schaffen sollte, sich zu qualifizieren, wäre er ja auch raus. Insofern ist das für ihn einmal doppelt tragisch. Und aber auch für Ajax sind da verschiedene Probleme, die sich dann eröffnen. Also, der Interimstrainer Fred Krim hatte in den letzten drei Start-Ausstellungen fünf verschiedene AVs ausprobiert. Meistens aus leistungstechnischen Gründen, oft aber auch aus anderen Verletzungen oder Sperren. Das heißt, man hatte eigentlich diese konstante auf den Außen-Teil-Kosition. Und die Lücke wollte man mit Zitelgo schließen. Und auf tragische Weise geht das nun leider nicht. Man muss aber aus All-Aksicht auch festhalten, dass sie sich trotzdem, seit ich es erwähnte, schon leicht angedeutet stabilisiert haben. Also in den anderen Mannschaftsteilen hat man jetzt so ein bisschen einen Gerüst sich draus gebaut. Also Casper Dolberg im Stor, Matvek Horst auf die Bank mittlerweile verdrängt. Das habe ich so auch nicht kommen sehen zum Beginn der Saison. David Klaassen spielt jetzt wieder den Kickstar, auch nicht kaputt. Der Routinier, der spielt jetzt auch wieder eine größere Rolle. Im Mittelfeld ist er eigentlich gesetzt. Und der Mika Hrotz in der Offensive, das belgische Talent ist es eigentlich schon nicht mehr. Das ist vielleicht auch schon die Stammkraft geworden bei Ajax und auch im Fokus anderer größerer Vereine. Der macht seinen Job auch richtig gut. Und deswegen konnte er dann auch ohne Sinchenko dann 4-1 gewinnen, jetzt gegen Südtat. Und es geht so ein bisschen unter, in der Liga hat Ajax seit November nicht mehr verloren. Echt? Ja, ja. Zwischen Tränen sind so Aussätze dabei, wie diese 6-0-Klatsche im Pokal gegen AZ. Oder auch hier und da mal ein Punktverlust in der Liga, unentschieden gegen kleinere Teams, die eben dann das Spiel ein bisschen trüben. Aber die letzte Liga-Näheanlage, die war glaube ich Ende November. Und das hatte ich so auch nicht, noch nicht auf dem Schirm. Aber es zeigt eben, dass Ajax sich verbalisiert hat, auch wenn noch nicht alles so rund läuft, sage ich mal. Aber in der Stelle nochmal gute Besserung an Sinchenko.
Aber wirklich. Und dann hast du es ja tatsächlich geschafft, den Kracher jetzt an diesem Wochenende zwischen NEC Nijmegen und Ajax auch noch von der anderen Seite zu beleuchten. Du bist einfach ein gottverdammter Profi. In diesem Sinne, ich danke euch jetzt hier Anwesenden noch dreien und den beiden Abwesenden auch noch sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit. Herzlichen Dank an Jakob Haffke, an Nils Kern, an Daniel Zander und natürlich auch an Christian Bernhard und Uli Hebel. Ich werde verlinken, wo man denen allen folgen kann. Vielen, vielen Dank für eure Zeit.
Schönen Abend noch. Gerne, gerne.
Bei Nils ist es jetzt schon Abend. Genau. Und da danke ich natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist werbe-payable und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Das haben getan Daniel, Flo2Speak, Raphael, Mirro, Seppo und Lorenz. Auf rasenfunk.de findet ihr einen Unterstützen-Button. Und da erfahrt ihr alle Informationen, wie man uns Geld zukommen lassen kann. Auch in der Video- und Podcastbeschreibung ist das der Fall. In diesem Sinne, danke für euren Support. Werdet oder bleibt gesund und bleibt uns gewogen. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.